hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video weiß nicht ob ich es sehen können
oder t shirt ist irgendwie hier so ein
bisschen dreckig also ich habe kein geld
mehr neues zu kaufen
hier seht schon sehr eingebildet mum
seite gehen soll und zwar kennt ihr
diese sounds können jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht viel mit anfangen wie ihr
vielleicht wisst bin ich im jahr 1996
geboren und jeder jahrgang
beziehungsweise immer so eine gewisse
spannung von so ein paar jahren hat er
die gleichen interessen oder gleichen
sachen mit denen sie halt groß geworden
sind und ich will das heute gar nicht
auf irgendwas spezielles beziehen
sondern einfach auf sounds die halt nur
leute kennen die hallen vielleicht jetzt
nicht gerade fünf jahre alt sind
soll man halt irgendwie aus den 90ern
kommen der erste satz den ich meine ist
dieser hier
da denkt man jetzt erstmal so okay das
ist das denn für mich war es relativ
schnell klar und zwar das ist einfach
diese serie disneys große pause gab es
halt immer wird ihre typischen
schulkinder zu diesen komplett coolen
die streberin die petze und so das war
einfach mega cool also diese serie habe
ich auf jeden fall früher die ganze zeit
geguckt
ich glaube hier wissen eigentlich sehr
viele beziehungsweise wenn ich sogar
alle auch wenn sie nicht in den 90er
geboren wurden worum es hier geht und
zwar um könig der löwen ich war früher
einfach ein riesiger könig der löwen
feiern und meine schwester und ich habe
immer auf dem weg in urlaub bei meiner
eltern im auto könig der löwen geguckt
aber der mann teil 1 teil 2 und teil 3
war glaube ich dieser hakuna matata teil
mit simon und pumba ich war meine ich
sogar schon mal in hamburg in diesem
musical banking das war auch megageil
dieser ton war wie die symbolisch für
meine alltag in meiner kindheit und zwar
dass der windows xp sound mittlerweile
bin ich nie übelster apple fan und
arbeiten nur mit meinem macbook meinem
imac und meinem iphone und hab alles
miteinander connecten aber früher
weisheiten wie es apple war früher
einfach kein ding es gab wunders und das
war's ich habe immer so spiele wie das
mit dem regenbogenfisch oder irgendwie
dass man die schuppen von ihm suchen
muss oder irgendwie mit diesem eisbär
namens keine ahnung mehr wieder hieß
aber das war auf jeden fall die einzigen
spieler die auf meinem laptop früher
irgendwie so dick war liefen passend zu
dieser sache mit windows xp kommen jetzt
auch schon zum nächsten sound
ich zeige euch mir hier direkt das ganze
mit bild weil ich glaube auch dass jedes
neunziger kind noch weiß was das war
auf den alten rechner gab es halt
irgendwie solche vorinstallierten spiele
und da gab's halt irgendwie keine ahnung
solitär und poker und halt auch dieses
pinball game und das waren wir mega cool
ist auf jeden fall auch einen sound der
meine jugend so ein bisschen beschrieben
hat also einfach dass man sich bettet
hat mit diesem pinball hochhalten und
ein ganzes peschl effekt ist es war mega
cool
das war der sound von nokia-handys wenn
sie entweder an oder aus gemacht wurden
bei mir war es so dass ich dieses nokia
63 00 oder irgendwie so hat und danach
noch den nachfolger ein bisschen besser
tasten hatten also die das dann echt
handy wenn also leute von heutzutage
sind mir diese bilder dass man mit nokia
in alles kaputtmachen kann aber die
teile sind einfach die ihn nicht kaputt
gegangen als ob ich zwei mal auf dem
spielplatz gerüst von oben aus irgendwie
sechs metern runter gefallen ist auf dem
harten boden und er ist einfach ein akku
raus kann man den akku wieder rein das
ding läuft das war echt krank
das ist der crazy frog nicht einfach
dass ich dabei ist bei uns in das spiel
gegen das auf meinem handy hat und das
war das einzige video was ich drauf
hatte da muss immer hin und her
geschickt etwa freiheiten richtige aktiv
musik aufs handy zu packen jeder
schulzeit freund von mir hatte das auch
gegen diese als klingelton wird
irgendwie einer angerufen wurde und
dieser crazy frau einfach so bescheuert
ich weiß nicht ob das video noch
irgendwo auf youtube gibt oder so aber
auf jeden fall mega crash das auch schon
die letzte anwendung für heute ich hab's
euch direkt mit bild gezeigt uns war
dieser nintendo ton er wird dann halt
früher keine playstation 4 und xbox
morgen die fertig wie schnell hochfahren
oder hochgefahren sind sondern einfach
dieses klingen
und dann kam das nintendo logo
sorry dass ich das video ist relativ
schnell beenden muss aber ich habe ein
termin und muss relativ schnell los
deswegen bist du bereit ist wieder nicht
so krass gestanden wurde wie meine
sonstigen glauben wohl eigentlich
ständig das auf dem weg also wurde sei
nicht normal geschnitten aber es hat
einfach nicht so lange bevor ich hat das
video gefallen als es getan hat will ich
mich über live freuen
wir sehen uns wieder und schreibt mal
die kommentare welche sounds für euch
noch symbolisch für eure altersklasse
was meinen sie